en un juego de lotería un jugador elige
cuatro números distintos entre 1 y 60
así que no puede repetir ningún número
se eligen aleatoriamente 4 números
ganadores distintos nuevamente entre 1 y
60 si los 4 números elegidos por el
jugador coinciden sin importar el orden
con los 4 números ganadores el jugador
gana cuál es la probabilidad de que los
números ganadores sean 3 15 46 y 49 pues
bien esencialmente lo que nos están
preguntando es cuál es la probabilidad
de elegir estos cuatro números ganadores
entre todas las combinaciones que se
pueden hacer dónde estoy eligiendo
cuatro números distintos de entre 1 y 60
así que primero vamos a calcular cuántos
posibles resultados podría tener esta
lotería pues tengo 60 números 60 números
y de esos 60 números voy a elegir 4 sin
que me importa el orden aquí lo hice sin
importar él
así que esto esencialmente es las
combinaciones de 60 elementos tomados de
cuatro en cuatro ahora bien hay una
fórmula para esto hay una fórmula que ya
deberíamos saber que es las
combinaciones de 60 elementos tomados de
cuatro en cuatro es igual a 60 factorial
entre 60 menos 4 factorial
4 factorial x 4 factorial ahora bien a
pesar de que tenemos esta fórmula
siempre es bueno siempre es bueno
volverla a derivar para asegurarnos de
entenderla veamos este cacho de aquí
este primer cacho que es pues 60
factorial es 60 x 59 x 58 x 57 etcétera
etcétera así que tendría 60 x 59 x 58 x
57 x 56 por 55 etcétera hasta llegar a 1
060 menos 4 factorial es simplemente 56
factorial así que eso sería 56 x 55 x 54
y cancelaría a todo lo que le sigue
estos 4 números así que este primer
cacho es esto de aquí y tiene sentido el
primer número lo podemos elegir de entre
60 números el segundo lo podemos elegir
de entre 59 porque ya usamos un número
el tercero entre cincuenta y ocho porque
ya usamos dos números y así
sucesivamente pero nos falta dividir por
este cuatro factorial
y ese 4 factorial porque está ahí pues
esencialmente ese 4 factorial representa
el número de modos que puede re como dar
los números por ejemplo digamos hacemos
estos números si me sale 60 luego 59 y
luego 58 y luego 57 eso es lo mismo que
si me sale 59 y luego 60 y luego 57 y
luego 58 porque no me importa el orden
así que ese 4 factorial lo que me dice
es divide entre cuántas formas puede
acomodar esto y el primer número lo
puedo poner en cuatro lugares distintos
el segundo en tres el tercero en dos y
el último en uno antes de sacar la
calculadora voy a reducir un poco esta
fracción 60 entre 4 es a 15
15 entre 35
58 entre 2 es 29 y el 1 lo puede ignorar
así que mi respuesta de cuántas
posibilidades hay para la lotería sería
5 por 59 por 29 por 57 y ahora sí voy a
sacar mi calculadora ok entonces 5 por
59 por 29 por 57 y eso es 487 mil 635
así que esto de aquí lo voy a escribir
abajo esto es igual a 487 mil 635 que
cosa pues son las combinaciones
distintas combinaciones combinaciones
distintas cada uno de estos eventos es
simplemente elegir cuatro números
distintos de entre 1 y 60 y lo que nos
pregunta el problema es cuál es la
probabilidad de que los números
ganadores sean 315 46 y 49 pues
que seleccione estos cuatro números al
azar es simplemente uno de estos
cuatrocientos ochenta y siete mil 635
eventos así que no escribo la
probabilidad de que los números
ganadores ganadores
podemos escribir la de bien ganadores
sean
315 46 y 49
es simplemente uno
una de las combinaciones de entre 480 y
7 mil 635 combinaciones posibles
esta es la probabilidad de elegir esos
cuatro números de entre 60 números
disponibles